[Music]
we're here at the Crescent dunes solar
energy project just inside Tonopah
Nevada
[Music]
this is really the first commercial
scale facility utilizing this technology
[Music]
it's a solar power plant with the
capability of storing energy in the form
of molten salt most conventional
renewable energy projects wind or solar
struggle with intermittency issues so
you get variations throughout the day
they're really looking for nice
predictable firm supply and that's what
we can provide one piece which is 80% of
the plant is just a regular steam
turbine conventional power plant
it's the 20% of this plant that is
different than anything in the world
we take molten salt in a tank and we
pump it up to a tower it's surrounded by
a huge field of mirrors that we're
standing in focuses the sun's energy and
a heat exchanger that sits on top of the
tall tower and it heats that molten salt
up from 500 degrees to over a thousand
degrees Fahrenheit we then store that
salt in a large tank and then we can
utilize it for energy generation when we
need to storing the salt allows us to
then move the electricity production
around to meet the peak demand of the
utility
[Music]
the tower behind me is surrounded by
over 10,000 heliostats the heliostats
themselves are actually tracking mirrors
that are computer-controlled
to track the Sun to deliver the
concentrated energy of the Sun to the
top of the tower when the heliostats are
first installed in the field they're
initialized and calibrated and then
they're turned over a computer this
computer directs the heliostats were to
go what to do so essentially the
algorithm knows exactly where the Sun is
and to direct and concentrate its energy
onto the top of the tower right now
we're standing inside of this massive
stainless steel tank a salt that will be
in there will be in a thousand 50
degrees Fahrenheit in a molten State we
want to make electricity they'll start
up our pumps and pump the hot salt
through heat exchangers and super
heaters and make the steam to be
delivered to the steam turbine to make
electricity and delivered
this material is a very high density
material that gives it the properties to
store an abundance of energy it is very
easy to handle and move can be operated
at high temperatures there's very little
concern on hazardous chemicals and those
kinds of things molten salt in this form
is is not a hazardous material from an
environmental standpoint we utilize zero
conventional fuels to generate
electricity so it's a zero mission
facility for the life of the facility
if you look at whether or not solar
could provide a percent of the
electricity supplied at some point in
the future the answer really is yes
you
[Music]